a medea family funeral was supposed to
be the final film appearance of medea
and yet here we are with the medea
homecoming so
when you did that last film did you
truly feel like you were really done
that was it that was the last time we
were going to see madea on film or were
you always thinking somewhere down the
road she'd come back because she just
can't help herself no 100 i thought that
was it i was you know tired of doing the
character it had been a good run
but looking at the state of the world
and everything that's happening i wanted
to do something to make people laugh and
i'm like what do i have in my toolbox to
make people laugh and it's clearly madea
so i just wanted to bring that out yep
was that need for laughter also what led
you to producing substract3 because
obviously that's
a movie that people have asked for for a
long time but those are films that just
make people feel good that's exactly
right i think we're at a time right now
where we're missing a lot of that
because so much is going on but yeah
that's a major part of it just my love
for whoopi and also just wanting to be
sure that that that movie got made so
absolutely
how close are we to that being shot
we are very close our script's going
well and we just do another round of
notes on it we're really happy about it
you do something very interesting with
this medea movie and that you wanted to
make people laugh but you also merged
that with serious sociopolitical issues
so how do you gauge and balance that so
that the humor is there but that you
aren't actually poking fun or making a
joke out of the issues that you're
spotlighting yeah well that's exactly
what i wanted to do not poke fun but
just make sure that i was highlighting
them but using laughter to be the
anesthetic to get us to talk about it so
i just think that so much is plaguing us
as a society we need to at least address
some of it and i thought hey maybe this
is a way that medea could say we should
at least be talking about these things
do you have like an internal gauge for
yourself to where like if something
feels like it's going too far or that
you need to go funnier with it is that
just sort of like a gut feeling
well that's that's probably 30 years of
being on the road in front of an
audience that and trying new things and
ad-libbing every night to see what works
and what doesn't so they've they've
trained me they're in my in my soul in
my ear i can hear them when i feel like
i'm going too far or it's just enough
you have quite the co-star in this with
irish comic brandon o'carroll as as
agnes brown i love the two of you guys
together what was it like to go
head-to-head with him
he you know
i tell you brendan is so funny his
timing is so amazing so to have somebody
on camera that that i could spar off of
that wasn't you know the in my original
gang was really awesome and our careers
have been on parallel tracks for many
years so for us to finally get together
to do some work together was was a dream
come true for me
what's it like to put a character that
you know as well as medea into
situations with a character like that
what is the most fun about having him as
a scene partner and feeling out how to
react to his approach to the comedy the
amount of ad-libs that he comes up with
and his i had to remind myself to stop
watching him because he's so funny and
not laugh but just the amount of ad-libs
he come up he comes up with the level of
of uh just comedy that's in his brain is
really amazing i feel like i would love
to see a road trip with those two
characters but at the same time it might
be terrifying how funny would that be
right a road trip that would be
hilarious okay i'll remember that
well you have this film about this young
man in college you're on netflix you're
calling this the medea homecoming so i
can see how you connected those dots to
beyonce
and i i won't spoil this before the
movie is out but i have to ask what made
you take things a step further and go
full beyonce with this i just you know
we're going to do homecoming and you
know the story you know about the kid
coming home from college was the story i
already had i thought if we go and you
know she already did this homecoming
thing let's just go for it as an homage
to the end credits and we did what was
that like to shoot what was that like to
see yourself in the full get up the
first time you did it i i've never been
high doing an interview but i definitely
had to smoke a joint to be able to get
through that whole thing so just know
that i had a couple of puffs before i
could hit that stage that was a lot for
me that was extreme how long did it take
to to stage all of that i mean it just
it was insane to watch yeah we did it
over a few days we were just having fun
man it was just just having fun
as i was watching it i kept thinking
like no this can't there can't be more
and they're just kept being
more of it so
how how did you channel your inner
beyonce
first of all i'm a huge huge huge fan
and before i did that the first person i
called was her say hey take a look at
this how do you feel about this if she
laughed herself too silly so i thought
okay we got the right thing to do so um
but yeah i'm a huge fan and she's a
friend and just having an opportunity to
do that was really awesome was there
ever a point when you regretted doing
that or were you just all in once you
decided this oh no once i'm in i'm all
in i'm all in we'll see what happens
after the movie comes out if i regret it
or not
i mean i could have just watched the
whole movie of that it was
i'm glad that we got as much of it as as
we did because it was crazy
yeah
well you also finally got to make a jazz
man's blues which
is crazy to hear that that's from the
first screenplay you wrote back in 1995.
how does it feel to finally have made
that film
i i it was the most fun i've ever had on
set and it was the most
enjoying time i've ever had at any movie
taking my time to be able to to film
this movie was was beyond anything i've
ever could imagine the cast is
phenomenal and i cannot wait for people
to see it
it's going to upset the apple car
because nobody's expecting this from me
what can you say about what we can
expect from it because it does it sounds
it sounds so different from anything
else you've done well being set in the
40s and having this incredible cast who
who took my words and made them come to
life
it's i'm just really really proud of the
work and i i i don't
i don't take that i don't say that
lightly i'm really proud of everything
that we put on film with it you were
named showman of the year in 2020 you're
this major player who leads your own
studio in hollywood and you've had
massive success in film and television
you kept people safe and working during
the pandemic and you make a difference
in your community so are you able to
actually really take that in and enjoy
it or are you someone who's always
focusing on the next thing or the next
several things
i i'm always focused on the next several
things and i i think that usually when i
get a break at some point in the year
when i actually stop down and take a
minute is when i really realize you know
the impact and all that's going on and
it's it's it's really an overwhelming
feeling of gratitude when i have that
it's it's just it's amazing to hear that
you know not only
are you making you know all of this
great project for projects for all of us
to enjoy and to laugh and to have tons
of entertainment but the fact that you
kept so much of that going during the
pandemic is just
i mean it's crazy
yeah yeah we didn't stop because i
realized i had a lot of people working
for me who had bought houses and you
know family and kids in college and new
cars and all these things so we had to
keep going and and we found a way and it
was great without one positive case we
got through the whole pandemic at that
time at the top of the pandemic so would
you say madea is back now are you
retiring her again no how do you feel
about her at this point i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna let it play out whatever
happens happens so we'll see we'll see i
thought it was so interesting too to
hear that you're developing a prequel
series mabel i mean
how did what did that come from well you
know i wanted to her her life in the 70s
was always really interesting to me so i
wanted to hire a real actress to go in
and play the role and see what that
would be like so we're in the beginning
of processes of writing that script to
see what happens does it feel like there
are still surprises about medea to
uncover
i you know i know her pretty well so it
would be pretty interesting for anything
to surprise me because she's she's
pretty much done it all you've had some
great actors appear in the medea films
is there anyone you'd still like to get
to do a film or to interact with her in
some way you know i've had everybody
that i've wanted but i think that oprah
would be pretty funny to have her doing
soccer to media so we'll see about that
have you ever tried to get her to do it
yet or i have not i have not
so so there are still there are still
goals there with medea for sure for sure
well i appreciate you talking to me
about this i laughed
just tremendously throughout the film
and i absolutely loved the whole beyonce
tribute so thank you thank you i'm glad
you enjoyed it thank you thank you for
going all the way in with that yeah i
did i did okay thank you
you